Well, let's take a look.
Suppose our word rule comes first, just like it does here on the page in some sense.
Hello is definitely a word, but actually,
world in quotes is also a word because this quotation mark
is not a space, a left angle or a right angle.
If this comes first, we get word, word, which would make us very unhappy.
On the other hand, if it comes after string,
then we'll end up getting the behavior that we're expecting.
However, probably this whitespace rule
actually has to come first
lest we confuse whitespace and the body of strings.
Our word rule precludes us from including spaces as parts of words,
but our string rule really does not, so we probably want our whitespace rule
to come if not first, somewhere near the top.
That means that our word rule is the one that comes last.
If our final ordering is either whitespace, string, word,
string, whitespace, word, we'll get the output we expect.
Let's walk through the first one and see how it goes.
We'll start with the h in hello. Does that match whitespace?
No, it does not. We'll try our next rule.
Does that match string? No, it doesn't start with a double quote.
Could it match word? Oh, it totally could.
And now we'll use our maximal munch power, and it will eat up the e,
the l, l, o, comma,
but it's going to stop because whitespace has higher priority.
We'll see the word hello,
then we'll see the space.
Does that match the whitespace rule? It does, so we'll pass over it.
Then we'll see these double quotes. Does that match the whitespace rule?
No. Does it match the string rule?
Yes, it does.
Maximal munch will take us all the way to the end of this token,
and we get the output we expect, and the second case behaves similarly.